California gets earthquakes which means
that the building codes here have some
pretty strict requirements there's a lot
you can do with computer simulation but
at some point new building techniques
have to be tested in the real world the
massive 10-story building behind me has
been constructed to test and certify a
new design a post-tensioned rocking wall
basically there's a massive heavy wood
and steel spine that runs all the way up
from the floor to the roof bracing and
dampening the whole thing which along
with new fireproofing might allow wooden
buildings to be far taller than ever
before does it work well to really test
it you need an earthquake so we're about
to get one the building is sitting on
the shake table here at the University
of California San Diego this whole site
is locked down because that table is
ready to go there's about to be a test
but I was here a few months back while
that building was still under
construction and one of the folks in
charge showed me round while everything
was powered down we started in the
equipment building where there's
colossal accumulators and pumps that
pressurize hydraulic fluid to 5000 PSI
which more than 100 times the pressure
of your average car tire this is really
big engineering so how much can the
shake table move if you're going along
the long axis the X direction we can go
plus minus 35 inches going in the the
lateral the y axis we can go plus minus
15 inches and then the Z up and down
that's plus minus five we have the
largest payload capacity in the world we
can move 2 000 tons so about 5 million
pounds of mass this 10 story building is
about 700 000 pounds total so that's a
maybe 10 15 of our capacity wow yeah
they're going to shake a 10-story
building back and forth and it's not
even a big deal for them also it's not
just up down sideways the shake table
also does roll
pitch and your when it was originally
built about 20 years ago it did only go
back and forth in One Direction they can
still do that they can shake in precise
mathematical sine waves if they want to
for a particular experiment but these
days they can also replay actual records
of real-life earthquakes although that
turns out to be far more complicated
than I thought before we build anything
on it we need to do some tuning for the
control system so bear table when
there's nothing on the table we do some
tuning then when you put the specimen on
those Dynamics the specimen Dynamics
actually affect the control Loop right
so we need to do some further tuning and
actually filter out some of those
frequencies in order to successfully
move infected oh because if the building
that you've made has a resonant
frequency
it interferes with the control system
right so we need to filter out those
resonances so you're not just playing
back an earthquake you're trying to get
as close to that as possible
while dealing with whatever the building
wants to do as you shake it right if you
do multiple shifts so the first few
tests to the building hasn't been
altered in any way then the building
might shift or break or you might change
you might change something right and
that might affect the controls next up
on the tour was the connector between
the power building and the shake table
where again there is stuff that feels
like over engineering Until you realize
just how much mass this thing has to
move everything here is color coded so
the red is high pressure Blues return
these large pipes here they're 12 inch
diameter they're like over an inch thick
inside this pipe is 3000 PSI pressure I
feel like at
something that had to be really
carefully engineered every time every
time 3000 SI fluid has to change
direction you're going to get water
hammer off oh absolutely the hydraulic
shock right that's the term it will add
vibrations to the table itself exactly
it'll cause a lot of headache not to
mention the damage that it could do if
one of these connections breaks then
you're getting you know 3000 psi oil
shooting everywhere and that's why the
whole area is locked off right now
everything is charged up warning lights
are flashing a test is about to happen
it's very unlikely there'll be anything
wrong this is not the first test they
started small a few weeks ago they're
working up the safety margin is massive
but right now inside and under those
buildings is not technically a safe
place for humans just in case so from
here 5000 PSI in the accumulators 3000
psi running through these pipes at who
knows what speed right
and they come over here and make a
u-turn
we have a dance
system here
so this was very highly engineered to
make sure that everything was okay don't
ask me exactly why there's a U-turn in
the pipes it's to do with retrofitting
new improvements around existing
concrete structures but I do know that
no sane engineer would put a U-turn in
that pipe unless they absolutely had to
now we're actually under the shake table
so this is the shake table Platinum the
10 story building is currently sitting
on it this is what we move everything
you see on this side is mirrored so
right now we're on the south side we
have six vertical actuators so there's
three of them on this side three of them
on the North side the vertical actuators
do the the up and down movement and then
the roll and the pitch movements okay
right oh yeah because you can actually
each one A different amounts right you
can lift one and drop the other and
they're not actually attached to the
shake table so this thing is a Glide
plate the vertical actuator actually has
a 32 inch diameter circular surface and
that creates like a vacuum chamber
between the Glide plate and the surface
very low protection that vacuum gets
filled with oil so when we push the
actuator up that table gets lifted up
with it but it can still freely slide
around what we definitely don't want is
for them that seal to ever open right
yeah you don't want the extra to be
unseated uh from that we're laughing
without the catastrophic that wouldn't
be catastrophic right so last stop on
the tour we've seen how it moves up and
down next is the side to side right over
our heads are horizontal actuators
on either side and they're the ones that
allow the X and Y and that yaw motion
these are what we call hold down struts
they're passive actuators if you will
they're basically a piston with nitrogen
filled on one side right constantly
applying a downward Force okay so we
have three of them there's a couple of
reasons for it one is remember when I
said we don't want those vertical
actuators to ever unseat right so you're
always pulling down okay you're never
gonna unseat those and the other one
would be for the overturning moment of
the the Shake table we have a 10 story
building on it if it wants to tip over
it's going to want to lift so it's
always getting pulled down for safety
always a restoring Force yeah I want to
just make that clear they're constantly
pulling down on the table because that
building on top can have so much inertia
that it might just want to keep tipping
over so it's got to fail safe the amount
of Safety Systems here if anything trips
presumably everything just shuts down
everything shuts down but it's a
controlled shutdown you can't leave it
off axis and you can't just be like okay
Return To Zero immediately because you
can right you might actually do more
damage on that that reversal it has to
be a controlled slow ramp down to bring
it back to zero position so here we go
the area around the building has been
cleared the scientists in the control
room are going through the startup
sequence this is just one test in a
hundred another routine earthquake I
don't mean to undercut the drama here
but the point is that the building will
survive this is not testing to
destruction they're not even going to
100 power this is just another day for
the shape table
I know it's fine but I do want to turn
and run I absolutely want to turn and
run
wow
10 minutes
all right